tous les murs de ce côté-ci et tout
l'extérieur ont été cassés refait à neuf
avec isolation le seul mur qui est resté
enti c'est celui-ci sinon tout a été
cassé et refait la maison de Rachel
comme neuve les travaux ont permis de
réparer les dégâts il y a un an sa
propriété était dans l'eau sa maison
inondée il avait fallu nettoyer en
urgence les réparations elles ont
ensuite duré 3 mois seul problème
l'assurance de Rach
elle ne couvrait pas tous les frais il y
en avait en tout pour plus de 13000 €
sachant que l'assurance verse 14000 si
je faisais ça par une société je pouvais
plus acheter lesmobiliers et j'avais
plus rien dans la
maison plus aucun meuble donc vous avez
décidé quoi de tout refaire avec des
amis et des voisins qui ont été inondés
aussi alors si corbeille ou encore
Juranville de nombreux pavillons ont été
inondés la faute aux précipitations
particulièrement forte mais aussi au
cours d'eau mal entretenu autour des
maisons et c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui les branchages à la surface
ou ça veut dire que les temps n'est pas
nettoyé ça veut dire que l' temps n'est
pas nettoyé ça veut dire qu'à un moment
donné ça peut aussi se réunir et faire
un un gros Hamas et barrer un peu l'eau
qui s'écoule et donc inondé à nouveau
inondé à nouveau un an plus tard tout
n'est donc pas réglé toujours à
proximité de chez Rachel ce bassin n'a
pas été nettoyé la mairie explique
qu'elle n'est pas responsable nous on a
demandé à ce que ce soit nettoyé encore
une fois c'est le syndicat du fusin qui
s'en occupe les les procédures
administratives sont très très longues
ça a été mis en route et ça a été la
priorité après les inondations de faire
nettoyer le lavoir c'est pas normal mais
c'est encore une fois l'administratif il
faut que ça remonte à la préfecture il
faut que tous les syndicats soient
d'accord il faut et c'est extrêmement
long aujourd'hui Rachel vit encore dans
l'angoisse comme elle de nombreux
habitants n'ont pas complètement tourné
la page je pense qu'on est tous
traumatisés c'est tous la petite encore
plus que nous parce que dès qu'elle voit
qu'il pleut elle surveille les temps
elle va à la fenêtre ou on passe devant
elle me dit maman il est monté ça va
encore inonder elle en parle encore
aujourd'hui la pluie continue de tomber
des précipitations moins abondand que
l'an passé mais qui pourrait durer une
bonne partie du weekend